[Music]
today the devastating news legendary
icon singer and Trailblazer Tina Turner
has passed away at the age of 83. in a
statement to E.T her rep says quote the
queen of rock and roll died peacefully
after a long illness in her home in
Switzerland one of the last times we saw
Tina on social media was in March of
2021 ahead of the premiere of her
critically acclaimed HBO documentary
Tina ah the Fourth of July is when I got
my freedom tributes have been pouring in
Jennifer Aniston said rest in peace
beautiful Legend Kelly Rowland called
tina a Queen Sarah Jessica Parker said
she was simply the best
I think when I look back over my life
I've lived quite positively
[Music]
Tina had an ageless spirit and it was
always a joy when each need to spend
time with her
the singer was almost 70 when she
invited E.T to this private Rock concert
in 2008 during our three and a half hour
visit she never slowed down how do you
stay so hip I mean you are so downward
you are are you kidding me right now I
know what you're telling me you're
saying to me you're 70 years old I know
that's what you want to say isn't it but
you're done with it next year I am I'm
70 years old I just have energy it this
I do nothing I've never done drugs
a little wine champagne on off days I
just don't need this is I was born with
this
Tina's career started with her first
husband in the Ike and Tina Turner
review in the 60s years later Tina
revealed that Ike's abuse nearly cost
her life it played out on the big screen
in the movie about Tina's life 1993's
What's Love Got to Do With It starring
Angela Bassett I'm Tina Turner
my husband and I just had a fight it was
always a black eye a broken nose a
busted lip I was totally finished with
the life and it was just a matter of
of cleaning just of leaving Tina left
Ike she was broke and turned to cleaning
friends homes they didn't like this oh
Tina how can you I was pleased I was
happy I needed to earn my way
at 44 Tina released her biggest solo hit
and her career skyrocketed selling more
than 200 million records it was 1977
when I left I Turner
my life is
progressed progressively climbed and
became better and better and better I
have no reason to think about this man
not even on stage the arrangements are
mine the musicians play as I want them
to play my my stage performances are as
I want them to be now not as how I would
have wanted I have gone on with my new
life
and it's wonderful
[Music]
that new light included a pre-game Super
Bowl performance in 2000 E.T was there
at rehearsal on the field and at her
side on game day how did it go out there
I won
you can't forget that ET interview Tina
33 times over the decades the first in
1981. it's fantastic to be here and to
do it and her look evolved Tina's
passion for rock and roll never wavered
I just feel like we'll finally my style
has caught up with itself because I was
obviously ahead of my own time
[Music]
in 2018 Tina launched her 50th
anniversary tour it would be her ninth
solo concert tour
[Music]
when it's easy to sing of course it's
fun but the hard part is weaving and
something different yet still giving
them the songs that they want to hear
and that kind of performance
[Music]
in 2013 Tina married German music
executive Irvin Bach 16 years her Junior
I found him quite attractive and I made
it known to him and I wasn't thinking
about age
[Music]
and Tina never looked back
when the show goes away what's the next
chapter be to be written for Tina Turner
oh that's interesting I think I'll
probably live to be a hundred
[Laughter]
someone said once she's got a fire in
her stomach and it'll never go out I
start to think about that it's probably
he's probably right I just have energy I
was born with this